you know the most famous native american
in american pop culture is the the
crying native american you know with the
teardrop at woodstock
that guy was italian he was a native
american
and now when you add in the transgender
ideology to the mix
all of a sudden it gets even more
confusing it's so confusing that even
family guy
which is a liberal channel or a liberal
joe rather
created by a liberal showrunner
seth macfarlane they even made fun of
transgender ideology in relation to
uh christmas and the nativity take a
listen
all right time to put up the 20 20
christmas decorations
first ethnically accurate jesus goes
right here next to father mary and
mother josephine
followed closely by the three genderless
wise people on their bird scooters
tig notaro for some reason and of course
the little drummer them
because god forbid we call a boy or boy
dad what are you saying i don't like
what the world is
i'm white when's it gonna be our turn
now this is actually a very complex joke
because it's seth macfarlane it's gotta
be somewhat blasphemous i'm just gonna
look past that for the moment
to analyze the joke uh because
uh because it's funny because
transgenderism
as an ideology doesn't make any sense
whatsoever
mcfarland who's a funny guy has to make
a joke about it
but because it's a liberal show he's got
to also make a joke at conservative
expense
so it begins with uh
this idea that jesus is black right
ethnically
it's a little black plaster doll who's
standing in for jesus he says ethnically
accurate jesus now
you wonder is this a joke about black
nationalism which says that all great
historical figures were black
or is this a joke about is it actually
the case that some people believe this
who knows
then you know he gets into all the crazy
gender stuff and dignitaro and right
there's a
comedian who's not the most feminine
comedian
and so okay now you realize you're
making a joke about that and he says
because we can't just call a boy a boy
and but is that is that going to be the
final point of the joke no they wouldn't
let him get away with it so then the
joke has to be about how
straight white guys are stodgy and
conservative and they won't
you know they they think that they're
the victims right so there are actually
like four jokes in this but one of the
jokes
which is a legitimate joke is at the
expense of gender ideology
but which is it we're in this moment of
flux we're in this music
where even this comedy show can't decide
which
i can't go for the fully conservative
target i can't go for the fully
left-wing target
[Music]
[Music]
you